bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france pour relancer
l'économie le trésor américain a donc
prévu d'emprunter 2999 milliards de
dollars par le biais d'émissions
d'obligations la somme est inédite
est-ce que selon vous l'état fédéral va
parvenir à trouver preneur en ces temps
bien trop bas le preneur il s'appelle
qui s'appelle la fed
donc c'est de la monétique de la
monétisation pure et simple de la dette
on le sait depuis le début d'ailleurs
depuis les premiers plans de relance
dont je rappelle le montant à 2300
milliards de dollars c'était déjà
colossale s'était déjà pratiquement
trois fois ce qui avait été mis sur la
table en septembre 2008 au moment de la
crise des subprimes voilà donc on est
passé à une toute autre échelle
quand on additionne les plans de soutien
du congrès
les achats de la fed on était déjà à
plus de 5000 milliards us 3000
on en est à huit mille milliards donc
aller grosso modo ça fait déjà 40 % du
pib américain qui a été mis sur la table
c'est absolument colossal est-ce que
cela va permettre au pays de se relever
comment est ce qu'ils se portent
aujourd'hui comment se portent les états
unis comment se porte l'économie a dupé
pas très bien et ça c'est un euphémisme
mais par rapport à la france l'italie
l'espagne mieux par contre moins bien
probablement que l'allemagne et les pays
nordiques
donc on va dire que les états unis
aujourd'hui haut en termes de
conjoncture se situe un petit peu entre
les deux mais ce qui ce qui importe
c'est comment les marchés vont
accueillir
effectivement les plans de relance est
ce que on va voir des investisseurs ce
se présenter pour acheter des t-bonds
américains ou au contraire vont-ils
préférer les actions
personne ne sait comment comment on
véritablement va se terminer cette crise
aux etats unis pas plus donald trump que
les meilleurs conjoncturistes donc pour
l'instant on va dire que c'est vraiment
de la navigation à vue et les sommes
annoncées
je dirais que personne ne peut
véritablement en mesurer l'impact dans
la vie réelle présente et future
donc c'est comment comment le marché
l'apprécient et c'est toujours le même
petit peu la même chose avec les
américains on a une vision toujours
optimiste des choses dans l'avenir et on
se dit que l'optimisme entraîne une
amélioration de la situation dont je
dirais qu'il ya ce pari parce que
injecté énormément d'argent
on a déjà fait ça or 2008 2009
ensuite on a continué avec des
quantitative easing massif jusqu'en 2014
aux états-unis au japon mené teese la
dette pratiquement depuis 1995 et le
trésor japonais à à elie des quantités
considérables puisque aujourd'hui on a
un taux d'endettement du pays qui est
250 pour son japon donc des sommes
considérables ont été engloutis
exactement le même le même genre
d'argent qui va être injecté est
question de savoir est ce que cet argent
on va bien arriver dans l'économie
réelle
ou est-ce que cet argent va continuer
d'alimenter la bulle des actifs virtuels
toute la question est là c'est comment
cet argent c'est 3000 milliards les 2300
milliards par ci les 1500 milliards par
là est-ce que cet argent va aller dans
l'économie réelle ce qui ne s'est jamais
produit 1 jusqu'à présent depuis 2008 et
depuis bien avant au japon est ce que
pour une fois enfin l'argent va aller là
où on prétend qu'il doit aller c'est
vraiment là la question
merci beaucoup pour votre regard
philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien